on va parler d'une solution pour nous
faciliter la vie à présent je crois oui
un tout autre sujet Aurélien vous
réussissez à enfiler une housse de
couette tout seul
je suis tout seul donc oui je me
débrouille mais oui c'est difficile
c'est ça ouais
et bien j'ai la solution pour faciliter
la vie grâce à une campagne de
financement participatif une start-up
tout range elle a mis au point une
innovation qui a reçu la médaille d'or
du Concours Lépine en 2019 ça s'appelle
opolie ça permet de faire son lit
rapidement et sans effort Benjamin Vatel
vous montre comment ça marche
commercial chargé de communication
gestion de projet ou encore gestion
administrative l'entreprise de Benjamin
a bien grandi depuis que l'idée de
l'enfile couette opolie lui est venu sur
son canapé en 2016 l'inventeur a fait du
chemin changer une hausse de couette
c'est du bonheur je vous présente hopoly
est une invention révolutionnaire qui va
changer votre vie en quelques étapes
simples vous enfilez une housse de
couette sur sa couette en moins de 60
secondes
après avoir passé 4 ans dans les espaces
de coworking de MAM son entreprise est
désormais implantée dans le centre de
Tours et compte 5 employés pour ça et
puis le mettre plus gros ok je pense que
tu en penses
et ça sera plus simple l'enfile couette
a séduit le public dès le début une
véritable success story pour ce tour en
joule d'adoption qui ne compte pas
s'arrêter là alors dans cinq ans je
m'imagine une dizaine ici donc faire
grandir encore l'équipe arrivé à sortir
deux produits par an donc chaque année
deux produits qui seront donc via un
crowdfunding une campagne de financement
participatif concours Lépine
systématiquement fabriqué en France ça
c'est important les ambitions de
Benjamin sont grandes et son équipe est
motivé à le suivre dans l'aventure ce
qui m'a plu déjà c'est l'esprit start-up
le fait que
on est tous ensemble on discute tous
ensemble et on avance les projets se
font comme ça
ensemble quoi il s'agit j'ai adoré
disons que c'était un challenge et la
fonction que j'allais occuper
m'intéresser étant donné que c'était
déjà quelque chose que j'avais fait
auparavant pendant 20 ans et voilà j'ai
voulu apporter mon savoir-faire en plus
de continuer à faire connaître l'enfile
couette opolie déjà présent dans 180
magasins rimatek va présenter dans les
prochains mois un nouvel objet un siège
de méditation créé par un ami de
Benjamin la passion de l'invention ça ne
s'invente pas